[Musique]
ayala comment allez-vous merci d'être là
je vais très bien sûr mon plaisir de
tous
si on devait décrire la musique que vous
faites comment vous la dcri et vous
parce qu'il ya des demandes qui fondait
d'exécution peut les lire dans votre
site web ou iam et vous personnellement
comment vous décrire et votre musique
le terme que j'utilise pour répondre le
plus simplement c'est c'est l'électro
sol par contre je suppose pour moi c'est
c'est plus une exploration de son à
travers tous les médias mme qui me sont
disponibles donc j'ai commencé par la
voix ce qui veut dire que mon travail
est quand même assez centré autour de ça
par contre là j'ai commencé à découvrir
des pédales qui me permettait
d'enregistrer ou d'échantillonner ma
voix sur place et à travers ça chalet
elle découvrir d'autres sont dans
différentes méthodes comme en utilisant
la production m soit live ou aussi en
studio ce qui fait que celui-ci
l'électro sol mais mais pour moi je
pense pas ça comme ça je pensais comme à
une exploration des sons que je peux
faire avec ma voix aussi avec d'autres
choses autrement
dans le fond c'est une puissance que
vous sentez à l'intérieur des vous que
ça sorte d'être des de manière ou d'une
autre il faut juste qu'il sorte
si jamais je peux même pas imaginer ce
que ça voudrait dire de pro pouvoir le
faire mais que ça soit par ces médiums
ou un autre la musique c'est il ya très
longtemps pour moi
ainsi
toujours la même un an
dans la mare
[Musique]
sûrement que beaucoup d'autres
journalistes vous sont posé la question
comment vous êtes arrivé à faire de la
musique parce que vous dites cela vous
fait la musique en français depuis
quelques temps mais comment vous êtes
arrivé à la musique tout court bien ça
fait depuis que je suis toute petite que
la musique fait partie de ma vie j'ai
une famille qui est qui est plutôt
musicalement pêche et est un musicien
écrit des chansons et joue de la guitare
alors ils jouaient toujours autour de ma
soeur et moi qu'on était petit et puis
un massa aussi en fait un musicien à ce
point ciel elle joue dans un groupe un
groupe appelé à ses murs à winnipeg
donc c'est ça on a un petit peu toujours
eu ça dans nos vies puis puis pas marqué
vraiment le point où vous ça commence et
c'est le début
oui c'est toujours été là ouais qu'on va
reprendre ses mais c'est pas envie
qu'est ce que vous attendez de l'album
qui va sortir après ce single d'accès
quoi vos attentes et je prends un peu
mon temps avec l'album ça va sortir
l'hiver prochain et puis j'ai vraiment
très hâte parce que je suis très fier de
l'équipe qui a travaillé sur le projet
et puis on a vraiment on est allé au
fond de chaque idée on a on a vraiment
beaucoup exploré puis c'est la première
fois que je lance quelque chose depuis
quand même plusieurs années donc je suis
tellement tellement contente et enfin
partager ça et puis bon j'espère que les
gens vont prêter leurs oreilles
je vous demande parce que les titres du
single c'est en attendant demain donc
attendre et qu'est-ce que vous pouvez
attendre
merci beaucoup rien c'est mon plaisir et
ma chance